alexis est pourtant un bon jour merci
d'être avec nous alors vaste opération
de perquisitions de béton s'y attendre
alors s'y attendre je ne sais pas mais
au moins c'est une bonne chose la cour
de justice de la république a accepté
les plaintes et continuent leur enquête
dans le cadre de cette gestion de crise
qui pose évidemment beaucoup de question
que ce soit au début en mars mais dans
la continuité de ce qu'on est en train
de vivre avec ce couvre-feu maintenant
et les urgences toujours engorgé ou du
moins d'être dans le rouge
donc c'est normal tant mieux que les
responsables soient sous le coup d'une
enquête mais encore une fois ces
perquisitions arrive tard dans leur
enquête
elles ont à la fois dans les bureaux et
au domicile des personnes en libérant
edouard philippe s'il est ndiaye
monsieur salomon tous les gens qui
étaient impliqués et agnès buzyn
également sioniste de la santé mais on
peut se poser la question en fait du
manque de contrôle sur l'exécutif sur ce
ministre qui n'en font un peu qu'à leur
tête ce président qui n'en fait qu'à sa
tête
parce que le parlement n'est plus que
l'ombre de lui même
le sénat reste encore un contre-pouvoir
mais à l'assemblée nationale c'est
devenu une chambre d'enregistrement de
ces mesures est finalement là où
l'assemblée nationale devrait être un
organisme de contrôle qui représente le
peuple qui serait là pour contrôler
l'action ministérielle l'action
l'exécutif ce n'est plus le cas et c'est
la justice qui se substituent et qui
doit faire les enquêtes là où on
pourrait avoir des enquêtes du du
parlement et et d'une surveillance de
chaque instant de la part des
représentants que sont les députés élus
là c'est clairement l'exécutif face à la
justice
complètement et ça commence à faire
beaucoup
puisqu'en ce moment on a également un
ministre de la justice le garde des
sceaux avec dupond moretti qui est en
guerre ouverte avec le parquet national
financier qui est qui est en guerre
ouverte avec des juges est en conflit
d'intérêts ouvert puisque ce n'est pas
lui qui va devoir trancher mais le
premier ministre jean castex donc dans
cette affaire là donc on a un
gouvernement du conflit d'intérêt et qui
se retrouve face à la justice
et c'est tant mieux si la justice peut
être le contre-pouvoir qu'elle doit être
c'est tant mieux et c'est souhaitable
mais ça ne doit pas être le seul
et c'est tout le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que c'était extrêmement faibles et
ces enquêtes vont prendre
extrêmement longtemps elles sont
compliquées pour mettre en place la
chaîne de responsabilité dans cette
mauvaise gestion de la crise sanitaire
donc on ne peut pas que attendre de la
justice qu'elle fasse tout le travail
qui devra être aussi dévolu à la
représentation nationale
alors tout ça c'est parti d'une
information judiciaire ouverte le 7
juillet pour abstention de combattre un
sinistre tous les perquisitionné un sont
concernés mais j'imagine que des parts
de responsabilité vont être établis oui
c'est à souhaiter parce qu'on se
rappelle annonces fracassantes d'agnès
busin lorsqu'elle quitte son poste pour
rentrer en campagne pour les municipales
à paris en disant qu'elle avait prévenu
qu'elle savait que le pire était à venir
et que c'était difficile pour elle de
faire campagne
pourquoi à ce moment-là n'at-elle pas
alerte et plus largement pourquoi
n'at-elle pas été dans son rôle de
ministre qui est de protéger elle était
ministre de la santé à l'époque
et puis toutes ces déclarations qu'on a
eue sur les masques alors ils se
défendent aujourd'hui en disant que l'om
est ce n'était pas clair sur
l'utilisation des masques
c'est faux que ce soit pour la crise du
h1n1 ou d'autres virus et d'autres
épidémies le masque était essentiel dans
la stratégie de lutte contre contre ces
virus
il a été effacé dans la doctrine contre
le corps adam jones parce qu'on en avait
pas assez et ça c'est un aussi un encens
ou une omission volontaire qu'il va
falloir creuser et qu'il va falloir
mettre à jour par l'action de la cour de
justice de la république
alors jean castex va parler normalement
à 14 heures est ce que le premier
ministre peut être dire un mot sur ces
perquisitions les terres complètement
alors c'est une bonne question je ne
sais pas s'il va les évoquer s'il parle
et qu'il ya des journalistes peut-être
que les journalistes vont poser cette
question à jean castex si c'est une
conférence de presse dans le cadre de sa
prise de parole et bat peut-être pas
parler naturellement de ces
perquisitions alors il pourrait
expliquer dans quel cadre elles ont lieu
pourquoi elles ont lieu aujourd'hui
comme vous l'avez dit c'est que des
plaintes ont été reçues par la cour de
justice de la république que les gens
qui sont aujourd'hui sous perdition
peuvent encourir des peines de 2 ans de
prison et 30000 euros d'amendé pour mise
en danger et atteinte à la santé
publique
et voilà donc je ne sais pas si jean
castex bas en faire grand cas où ce ne
serait ce que mentionner la procédure en
cours pas forcément ce n'est pas son
rôle et ce n'est pas forcément le lieu
ni le moment pour cette prise de parole
alors selon vous prêter des dons de
visionnaire selon vous est-ce que
olivier vers on va rester à son poste
après cette perquisition
écoutez pourquoi pas on a le précédent
gérald darmanin qui est visé par une
enquête pour viol et qui reste ministre
de l'intérieur on a eu d'autres
précédents on à richard ferrand qui est
au perchoir de l'assemblée nationale et
qui lui aussi est mis en examen est visé
par plusieurs enquêtes on a on a un
gouvernement quand même qui cumule les
casseroles et les enquêtes et ça
n'empêche pas les ministres en exercice
de rester à leur poste donc qu'est ce
qui ferait qu olivier véran serait
démissionner par rapport à un gérald
darmanin qui a eu aussi des enquêtes en
cours et en plus il s'agit là d'une
enquête de la cour de justice de la
république qui juge les ministres et
l'exécutif
donc je ne vois pas quelle serait la
logique a démissionné olivier ferrand au
coeur de la crise avec cette deuxième
vague qui arrive avec ce couvre-feu mis
en place et avec tout ce qui va avec
comment remplacer un mousse de la santé
en urgence alors que cette procédure est
en cours ça me paraît être quelque chose
d'assez délicat à gérer pour emmanuel
macron alexis un poulain merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes éditorialistes merci d'avoir
été en direct sur arte france